Regardez ce que j’ai trouvé dans mon jardin…
Si les oiseaux ne prennent pas froid et en particulier ceux qui passent une partie de leur vie sur l’eau
les canards, les mouettes, les goélands...
C’est parce que leur plumage est aussi étanche
qu’une combinaison de plongée.
Les plumes se chevauchent
comme les tuiles d’une toiture.
Chaque plume se présente sous la forme
d’un axe central, le rachis, d’où partent des barbes,
et de chaque barbe, des barbules
munies de petits crochets
qui leur permettent de se maintenir les unes aux autres pour former une couverture bien étanche.
Souvent, on voit les oiseaux fouiller leur plumage
avec leur bec.
Ils se recoiffent. Ils réalignent les barbes et les barbules,
et les enduisent d’une matière cireuse et hydrophobe,
produite par une petite glande
située au niveau du croupion.
C’est très léger, comme une plume…
ou une « capsule de déconfiné ».
Allez à demain et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.
Si vous avez aimé cette "capsule de déconfiné"
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour ne pas les rater,
abonnez-vous et activez la cloche.
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain...